(gentle piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked,
large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism,
we grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- Thank you everyone for coming,
and I'll just take a moment to tell you
a little bit about how we decided
to make like a CARTA meeting
entirely on human imagination.
This is one of those things that,
it seems to happen only in San Diego
where two people and I'm
talking about myself,
who I'm a professor in pediatrics
and cellular molecular
medicine, turns out to be
in a meeting sitting
together with Sheldon Brown,
who you're going to
hear as a first speaker,
and Sheldon Brown comes from visual arts.
So, a scientist and an
artist, we start talking
and we realized we have
something in common.
We are both fascinated
by human imagination.
So I make a challenge to Sheldon,
and say well can we put this
in a scientific context,
and we start planning
about a meeting like that
and we realized that most of the time,
when we try to understand something,
if it's unique or enhanced in humans,
we turn on to compare
our closest relative,
living relative, such as the chimpanzee,
and comparing to other
animals is difficult,
especially if you're
talking about cognition
and imagination, so this time,
I think you're going to
hear lots of speakers
talking about imagination in modern humans
and also in extinct humans
such as the Neanderthals,
and we hope that the combination
of all those speakers,
all this knowledge, will
help us to understand
a little bit about ourselves
and answer those questions
that Ajit posed to us.
- Okay, so we're going to
move into a new space in time
right now, we're going
to move into the night.
Some 3,500 years ago, humans
engineered control of fire.
It's actually quite complicated.
There was a huge caloric gain from food,
because cooked food makes
many more calories available.
Protection from predators,
but what's most interesting
about it is that humans extended the day
by four or five hours to become
the shortest sleepers of all primates.
And, the time that gained was
economically unproductive.
No more calories were going
in, nothing was happening
economically, and yet the physical changes
in ciracdian rhythms were
enormous to extend the day,
and there were some very major impacts
on health from reduction in melatonin
and other things, so there were costs.
So the question is, why?
You know why was this selected for,
why didn't we just go to sleep?
So what I'm going to suggest
here is that firelight
opened up a new time and space
for the imagination and for the arts.
There's the wonderful
quote from a German writer:
"Nobody sees anything in the night;
"everybody sees something in the night."
So, this is, the night is often
the time of the imagination
if I would define the
imagination for this talk
as the ability to form mental images
of something not present to the senses
and never wholly perceived in reality.
So, what transpires by day and night,
why do firelight hours matter?
Well this is not so easy to find out,
but I became very interested in this
among the Ju'hoansi bushmen
of Botswana and Namibia.
These are a group of people
who live by hunting and gathering.
They utilize about 100 plant species,
30 animal species, and in the hard times,
a few of them even have to gather water.
The only water they get is
from melon or from roots.
And they live in very small
camps of 25 to 40 people
with egalitarian structure, age hierarchy
and recognized camp leaders.
So the interaction, scale of interaction
in every day life is very very small.
And yet they have these
incredibly sophisticated
social institutions, and the question is,
when you live on a postage stamp,
you know, how do you see the big picture?
So that was my question,
to see what happens
in the day and the night.
Here are some of the cultural institutions
that they have: complex kinship systems,
defining both biological and
imaginary or fictive kin.
These systems are so complicated that I,
after 30 years of working there,
am still trying to figure them out.
(audience laughs)
Rules for widespread food sharing,
they have arranged marriage
and elaborate marriage rites,
sophisticated systems of land tenure,
trance healing in an
unbelievable communication
with the spirit world, and
then networks of xaro exchange,
widespread access to
the resources of others,
people move around, we'll see this.
So what happens at day and night,
that was my question.
And with data in 1974,
I collected information
on day and night conversations with groups
of five or more adults
longer than 15 to 20 minutes,
and then 2011 and 2013, I
collected the full stories
and had the transcribed and translated
by a team of Ju'hoansi who
are now working with laptops
and sending me the most amazing emails.
(audience laughs)
All the gossip comes through by email now.
So, the day talk which
was really interesting,
was the topics of conversation
are largely practical,
economic issues and planning,
an enormous amount of
complaint and criticism
(audience laughs)
as people get on to each
other's case, gossip,
and people say, "Well gossip
maintains social norms,"
but in fact I found 30
to 40% of the gossip
was just total bull--
(audience laughs)
It was constructed for social strategies.
And so you can see that, that was the day,
and then there's the switch to the night.
All day long as an anthropologist,
people are on my case to give me things,
to give them things, to help with things.
At the night, that's off limits.
Everything mellows off and
I don't get a single demand.
Isak Dinesen, or Karen Blixen, wrote,
"At times I believe that
my feet have been set
"upon a road which I
shall go on following,
"and that slowly the center
of gravity of my being
"will shift over from
the world of the day,
"from the domain of
organizing and regulating
"universal powers, into the
world of the imagination,
"with the coming of the dusk,
"with the lighting of the first
star and the first candle."
And that's the transition you feel,
so I looked at nights, at
36 nights, in four camps.
Eight nights were singing, music,
singing, gathering together.
Six nights were trance healing dances,
and most nights were
conversation and storytelling,
and that's where I
recorded the conversations.
And the results were quite astounding.
All you really need to do
is look at the orange here.
Oh actually the print is pretty big,
but you can see, in the
day there are few stories.
Economic complaint.
At night, people get
off each other's cases
and they mostly sit
around and tell stories,
and come together, and so the moods mellow
when the suns set, and I can tell you,
it's very harsh in the day,
because it's a sharing economy
and people are always mad
that he gave that to her and not to me.
And people gather around single fires
to talk and to story.
They talk about their own experiences
or those of others in a very entrancic,
entrancing, compelling rhythmic language.
The listeners are stunned with suspense,
rolling with laughter, close to tears,
and emotions are synchronized,
because everybody is
relating to the same story.
The people they talk
about are often people
who are 200 kilometers away,
and they bring that person
right to the hearth,
so delicious are the details of the story.
But the storytelling, what
I'm going to suggest here,
is that it gives the
big picture of society.
Good storytellers transmit
visions of social institutions
that are imaginary, like kinship system,
exchange systems, and they're
not present to the senses.
They're never wholly perceived in reality,
but the people, the few
people, like this old lady,
who can put stories together
to imagine the big picture
of society and tell about it,
they become very influential,
these are the organizers
and the mediators who have this skill.
This is an example of xaro exchange.
This is an exchange of gifts
where people choose partners,
up to 200 kilometers away,
that longest line there
is 200 kilometers, and this
is a social security system
so they keep exchanging gifts
and the underlying relationship is,
when you're in trouble, I'll help you,
you can come live with me,
and when I'm in trouble,
so that is the exchange.
The average person has about
15 or 16 of these partners,
and they usually spend about
two to three months a year
living with these partners.
This old lady is wearing all her gifts
to advertise herself because
she's trying to marry off
her grandson, and she's
showing how welcome she is.
And then, we have the
stories give the big picture
of regional gatherings, xaro exchange
and kin relations, and
the one story I collected,
it was from the 1940s,
six bands coming together
at a particularly good time of
year to harvest moramo beans
and this story goes on for pages,
and the relations between
the bands are described,
and the complex kinship
relations are described,
everybody named would
tell how they are related
to so-and-so and so-and-so, and so-and-so.
This gives you an idea of the area
from which people came for this gathering.
The whole thing would be about
oh, two or 300 kilometers,
north south, and this is sort
of an excerpt from the story.
Different people were
there, some were there
from the N/olau Eiseb Valley,
and some were Nharo
from the further south.
Some from the N/on/oni si
where there is a forest with
lots of combretum trees.
The norther people were there also,
they were called /Uisi also came.
The owners of N(clicking
twice)ola'a also came, so,
and then they tell how everyone
is related, this story.
And this is a story put together
from many that she had heard
because she was a little girl
when this had happened,
and then they described
what happened at the gathering.
This goes on for pages.
She got the other skin apron
and gave it to my late
grandmother N/hakxa n/a.
She took out another skin apron
and gave it to her aunt,
the late N=aisa n/a'an.
And then she gave out more gifts,
and then it was the
beginning of gift giving.
He, /Kagece, tried to
pull the beaded headband
on his head but it didn't fit,
so he took it off his head
and gave it to my granny
N/hakxa n/a and gave other things to her,
and this goes on and on and on, so.
And you don't only have stories
but for the other form of arts,
you have gifts, so that these partnerships
of mutual obligation are
marked by gift exchange,
beautifully made, artistically made gifts,
and these gifts represent relationships
but they also carry stories
of who gave them to whom.
They go through long chains of giving,
so you know, they create
these huge networks
so each gift would have
a history in stories.
And then another example
would be in marriage,
you don't see many marriage
when you live in a small band
of 25 people, you may see
a few in your lifetime,
and they're infrequent but the procedures
are elaborate, they're arranged.
Usually the girl is married
around 13 and rejects the man,
and makes a big fuss and
these stories are hilarious,
of old ladies telling about
how they rejected their husband
and ran away and destroyed
the wedding gifts
and this prepares young
people for marriage,
knowing that the first years
are going to be kind of rough,
(audience laughs)
and that they'll get used to them,
and then parents also learn
of all the case studies
of marriage told in stories
and they know how to manage them.
Okay, the other thing which
is people, N/uasi people do,
trance healing in which the
women sit and clap all night
and sing, and the men, the trance healers,
travel to the spirit
world where they negotiate
with the spirits, asking
them not to take people away,
to leave them on Earth,
that they love them,
giving everyone preventative medicine.
In these stories, the
trance healers at night
will tell about how far they traveled,
I mean, I was once
telling people how about,
we're sending men to the moon
and there's an old guy
who looked at me and said,
"Been there."
(audience laughs)
So, this is you know, you can imagine, so,
the trancers then, in telling the stories,
connect people with a shared cosmology,
a shared sense of the spirit world,
a shared sense of what causes misfortune.
So, sort of to wrap up then,
day, night and the imagination,
so the day, you have
economics, technology,
nitty-gritty of social relations.
The night, the stories
are about imagined roles,
rules, communities, that are not tangible
or physically coherent in time and space.
So they're imagining society
in their social institutions.
They also imagine as change comes,
they can also imagine, they can innovate,
and imagine changes as well.
And then stories stimulate imaginations
to construct the big picture
of social institutions
and relations, and very very importantly,
because we have theory of mind,
because we can read what
other people are thinking,
they really make people imagine
the thoughts and the feelings of others,
so that you can really understand
that people feel differently about things,
and it brings a lot of
understanding into it,
and people put themselves
in other people's shoes in the stories,
because they're so emotionally
laded, it's incredible.
So essentially what I found in this study
is that the evening hours provide a space
for the arts and for the imagination.
And the arts would include
also music, dance and stories,
and does this happen beyond the Kalahari?
We've moved up to the Arctic now.
Yes, these kinds of stories are told
in all hunter-gatherer societies at night.
If you look through the
human relation area files,
there are 38 mentions
of sanctioning gossip,
none of them is at night,
they're all in the day.
For 60 hunter-gatherer societies,
information on stories,
songs, healing and
ceremonies is in the files,
and of course as we all know,
we too hunt and gather stories
through theater, film,
recording, literature,
to feed our imaginations,
I mean we really are
as addicted as anybody.
So to end, and I just
want to as this question,
I often think about that.
What is, in our society, the
impact of checking the phone,
flipping off the light switch
with no time for the
imagination to explore,
to ponder, and to position
events and relationships
of the day in the past,
present and future?
And so these are thanks to my co-workers.
(audience applauds)
- Good afternoon, my
name is Pascal Gagneux,
CARTA Associate Director.
When Allyson and Sheldon and
I discussed the possibility
of this symposium, I immediately mentioned
the Kennis brothers to them,
Adrie and Alfons Kennis
are world famous paleo
artists from Holland,
and I contacted them and
they kindly agreed to come,
and we learned two weeks ago
that due to a family
tragedy, they couldn't,
but luckily we could convince them
to answer about 15 questions for us
in a brief video, in a filmed interview,
interspersed with some documentary footage
that has never been shown before.
So I hope you will enjoy
the upcoming presentation.
Adrie and Alfons Kennis
telling us how they go about
making such believable recreations.
- We are Aldrie and Alfons Kennis
and we make reconstructions of humans.
We started because we
were very bad at school.
We were not good in the mathematics,
we were not good in
reading, so the only thing
we could do was, make drawings of faces
and about animals and everything,
and the first, I show you one example,
two examples of the first
reconstruction we made,
are those two, and the
left, for you on the right,
you see it clearly
Combean, this Combean man,
and the left side for you,
this is clearly a Piki man.
And especially, when
we came in the library,
there were not so many books
about our human ancestors,
but one stick out, one
illustrator stick out,
and there was illustrator,
Zdenek Burian, from Czechia
and he made this beautiful, we thought
he made this beautiful
rough reconstructions
of mostly of example, Neanderthals,
so we were fascinated by it,
because we liked the characters,
we liked the rough style.
We went on vacation to one of my parents,
she went on vacation to Germany, to Italy,
and we traveled through these landscapes
Burian often depicted, because Adrie and I
weren't so fascinated by dinosaurs,
because dinosaurs was much
too alien much too far away,
we couldn't--
- Reptiles have no character!
- And we could not make a
world with only reptiles.
We could imagine a
world with humans in it,
and then with strange beasts in it like,
with rhinos, cave bears, even cave lions,
and we were fascinated by
this world where people lived
but if people walked around,
and when they could encounter
big lions and big mammoths.
(gentle chamber music)
How do you make reconstructions?
First, you need a skull.
We often get casts of skulls,
or we've made casts ourselves,
or, if you want to
reconstruct a total body,
we get bags of all elements of pieces,
mostly pieces of human skeletons,
and these pieces we try to put together,
to reconstruct a complete skeleton,
and for example here, we got a skull,
and it's missing its face, and we got only
a couple of bits of the face.
So we look in our big spare
part collection behind me.
We have an enormous
collection here of skulls.
In the drawers are also post cranial stuff
and in it here, you can
get all kind of bones
and pelvis pieces.
- It's our garage.
- Our garage, we're going
to look in our collection,
what type of human is this?
How old is it, you have to know of course,
and what type is it, and then
we look in our collection.
If we find other individuals
for the same timeframe,
and then we're going to
look at what our bits are,
are they the same type of morphology,
and then we try to recreate more or less
the face on the skull.
- This is end result of the
reconstruction of this face,
so we use this one as
base, we have this part
and all those loose parts,
and then we create new face.
If you see carefully, you see
the maxilla that was used,
the left maxilla of this face
is put here in this part,
and the nasal area, we
used also this piece
from Atapuerca, we use here,
so we can recreate a new face.
- But nowadays, lot of
skull reconstructions
are more made with scintigraphy.
They made, they scan the
bones so it's not necessary
to do this, to make
casts of the originals,
so we scan, the bones
are scanned nowadays,
and at home we've got a 3D printer
and you can print out the bones without,
I have to use silicones of originals.
It's even today possible
to make a reconstruction
from the skull while still in situ,
embedded in calcite in the cave.
This one is from Altamura and we got,
they managed to scan the skull in the cave
embedded in calcite, and then
we printed out the skull,
and then we were able to
make a reconstruction.
- This is the result of the skull,
and you see these small
pegs here in the face,
and those pegs resemble the skin thickness
in this part of the face.
So if you see here on the cheeks,
you see bigger pegs, longer pegs,
those are lot of more fat
tissue and bigger muscles,
especially here off the areas,
and this side, you see the
big muscle for chewing,
and big temple muscle here
and you see this peg is rather long
because the muscle is very thick.
On the nose, the skin is very thin,
and there are no muscles,
not so much muscles on it,
small ones, so you see the pegs,
the tissue thickness is very
small, is very not so big.
- To guide us with the
reconstruction and especially
to choose the right muscle size
and how the muscles are,
we look at dead corpses.
We dissect dead corpses of chimps,
and also we can look at the institutes
where they have dead bodies of people,
so we can...
- Recreate.
- Recreate the muscles
from the modern humans.
So these muscles guide us
with the reconstruction
of these in between human ancestors
who are a little bit
apelike in the face also,
especially the oldest
ones, but become more
and more and more humanlike,
so we have to look more
at the human muscles.
(gentle chamber music)
You must imagine, 'cause we live indoors
all the time nowadays, people.
These people, you must imagine
people 100, 200 years ago,
people work on the land, work
in the orchards and things,
I know people who work on the farms,
who in summer, got tanned very quick.
So people who live outdoors all the time,
especially in summer,
look probably pretty dark,
and that's why on Neanderthals,
we make all kinds of skin tests.
And this one looks like a
very, okay this skin test
is much too pale for a Neanderthal,
it was a failure, we have
hundreds of failures,
but this one was too pale.
So we try this other individual
but we tried to do it
in different colors to
make darker, darker,
dark so it looks more like a guy
who was living outdoors all the time.
We build our colors inside out,
so we start with dark pigmentation,
where real people maybe also have,
the dark spot, the darkest
layers, and then we work--
- Superficial layers, yeah.
- Yeah, superficial
layers, and then we make
layer after layer, more layers,
and why more layers, because then you see
nice different colors in the face.
You also see this guy here,
this guy from Jebel Irhoud,
this is one of the first homo sapiens
from 300,000 years ago.
If you see our skin color here,
there's a variation, he has more orange,
more purple, dark, he is more blackish,
so if you use more layers,
it looks more realistic.
In films in Africa, you
see this guy and stuff.
These are very neat, these
are the first Europeans,
the first Africans coming into Europe,
they look very neat, they
look very like a six pack,
and muscles--
- Couche muscles.
- Couche, idealistic people,
also the woman has the clothes
on the right spots, but why?
If we look at, if we see human evolution,
we look at anthropological pictures,
we should like this kind of stuff,
this kind of, why not like this?
- Instead of this?
- This ethnographic photographs inspire us
to see how this ancient
world of prehistoric men was.
This was a world very long ago,
beyond, mostly beyond our imagination,
because we, Adrie and I,
and a lot of the people
in this space are grown
up in the Western world
with a Western civilization.
This guy next to us looks
for us a bit nearly alien
for us, compared--
- Strange.
- With this European guy,
strange, but for him,
in his world, he's
normal, and this abnormal.
- Yeah.
- So we try,
if we make, we're trying
to make a reconstruction,
we try to kinda dive in this world.
If he were maybe in a Western museum,
we think Western, you see his testicles
are hanging under his shell,
but if we put him in a normal museum,
we'll put the shell over
his testicles for sure.
But this guy doesn't feel naked.
This guy feels himself
normal, he doesn't feel naked,
he stands in his world.
In his world, there's this
nice piece of necklace
here on his belly, you see,
and the West can have
big problems with it,
to confront people who kind of visit,
with children and families,
this naked guy could have some problems.
And our culture was 100 years,
or not 100 years ago,
it was also a bit weird,
because I don't, if you walk
on the streets this way,
nowadays, I think people would say--
- It's not the difference than this guy!
- Yeah.
- We also do kind of contrast in it.
- Contrast in it, if you
see this nice picture,
of a nice woman, nice child
is hanging on the breast,
nice female body, but
certainly if you see,
under her face, she is smoking a cigarette
and she's a bit, it
looks to me like a male,
kind of cigarette so she's got two things
in one view, you got a female
like on under side of this picture,
and got a male for her
(speaking foreign language)
- Yeah but it makes nice contrast,
and that makes authentic.
- And smoking.
(gentle chamber music)
- Then we have to
reconstruct the robust guy
and we se also robust guys
in ethnographic photographs,
then they don't stand robust,
they don't feel robust,
they don't stand as a
hulk, so this Neanderthal,
we made the reconstruction.
You see he's very robust, he
had enormous broad pelvis,
incredible broad pelvis, short legs,
but he stands very
relaxed, he stand not as,
"I'm strong man, strong man!"
He can be shy, he can be a shy guy,
he can be a shy Neanderthal.
- Introvert, introvert.
- And we also make sure
that he makes contacts,
it's also a bit, nice to
do, that a reconstruction
make contact with the visitor,
so our reconstructions
always look at you, so
you get a real feeling
you engage with ancestors,
you engage with somebody.
Yeah, you will see on Homo sapiens
earliest Homo sapiens, this Homo sapiens
was 300,000 years old, but you look,
it has a rough hair cut,
it has a rough face,
it has a strong body, it's
rather thin, but a strong body,
so what we thought, we
saw pictures of females
who are making themselves pretty,
and we thought why couldn't
this guy make himself pretty?
- Put some stripes on his body.
- White stripes on his
body, so he's doing kind of,
maybe a female thing, of what
we think be a female thing,
but his hand is very robust so
you have again nice contrast.
This is the way how people
stand if they even stand,
if they have no pockets.
- You leave your hands
somewhere, even very primitive,
all human ancestors walk
erect, have their hands free,
but if they just staring at something--
- Relaxed in an erect pose.
- They leave their hands somewhere,
and it's very interesting
on ethnographic photographs,
to see where people leave their hands
if they have no pockets.
- We do the active pose like hunting,
or like--
- Try to avoid it, yeah.
- Try to avoid it, of making tools,
because then you don't,
they have no connection
with the public and you don't
see the anatomy very well.
- We've made a lot of reconstructions,
so each time for us, the
face has to be interesting.
So, what we do, normally like to do,
is building a contrast in the face
and for almost kind of
tension in the face,
and for example here, this
child is a Neanderthal child,
has a broad big mouth, she's
a little bit laughing at you,
but it's not a complete easy laugh,
it's not completely easy
to see, it's still hiding
in the face where the
laugh will burst out,
but she's still in the face before,
she's not laughing right out.
The same have we done with this face.
This boy, this boy Neanderthal, bit older,
but he also, he's just,
he's not laughing right out,
it's just something starts
to happen in this face.
- 'Cause here are two examples
from sketches, two sketches.
They look very similar.
There's a very nice face, a bit woman
but there's also nice
contrast in the face.
You see, for us, we think
rather aggressive nose
with the nose holes turned up, upwards.
And then maybe put some
friendly eyes above it,
and we give her a friendly
smile so we get nice contrast
with a bit aggressive like
nose and a friendly smile.
And sometimes we go too
far, we can go too far.
This is another sketch,
and here she puts the mouth
a bit already open, but we think then,
when we make this thing, that is too much,
because the mouth is
open, you got to look now
also at the nose and at the mouth,
but the mouth attracts too
much attention from the nose,
so that's why we prefer
to do the mouth closed,
so it's, you see nice contrast
of the aggressive nose
and the friendly face.
(gentle chamber music)
- I will, I'll show the work that we do,
and in a way it's quite
similar to the Kennis brothers.
We try to reconstruct
parts of the Neanderthal,
but instead of body parts,
what we try to do is
reconstruct their minds.
One day I imagined that would be possible,
and I don't have a
brother to challenge me,
to keep it going, but I have a whole team,
and this whole team
helped me to achieve that,
and that's what I'm going
to share with you guys.
So we start with the idea
that perhaps we should study
human imaginations by
comparing to other humans,
perhaps, humans that have a
different kind of imagination,
either worse or better, just different.
And we thought about Neanderthals,
and part of the reason
is because we know more
about the Neanderthals
than the other extinct hominids,
and we also shared our world
with them for a long time.
It becomes clear, and I think
you guys all learn about that,
that during the time
period of the Neanderthals,
on Earth, I mean, they
developed these stone tools
and definitely make it better,
but the technology
didn't go as far as that,
and in contrast, we modern humans,
in a very short period of time,
we could create not only stone tools,
but a whole set of new technology, arts,
and sophisticated ways to
communicate with each other,
so which points out
that perhaps our brains
are somehow different from them.
So, how do we study the Neanderthals
and how we can start
tracking these questions?
So we have bones, we have endocasts
that we can predict how their brains
would have different shape or volume.
We have DNA.
We can extract DNA from
bones of Neanderthals,
and we have impressions and
someone might call that art,
others might not think that this is art,
but they definitely left some impressions
for us to try to understand.
So from the endocasts, this
is the work from the group
from Leipzig, in Germany,
they have confirmed
that their brains, at
least in terms of volume,
is not so different than us.
They actually have a
little bit larger brain
compared to what we have.
But, I mean the endocast
doesn't offer too much
in terms of how that
brain actually functioned.
So, Svante Paabo, also
from Leipzig, is a pioneer
on isolating the DNA from the Neanderthals
and sequenced them so
we can actually compare
the Neanderthal genome
to the modern human's.
So this is all nice, but actually,
how do we understand the Neanderthal brain
or the Neanderthal mind in a dish?
So I come from a stem cell background
and in stem cells, we have something
that's called brain organoid,
also called a mini-brain,
because we can recreate those
using human pluripotent stem cells.
They don't look like that.
(audience laughs)
They're actually a simplified,
miniaturized version
of the human brain, and we have a recipe
that we developed in the
lab, that is quite good
to make a functional mini
brain, or brain organoids,
and it always starts from single cells.
These are similar to embryonic stem cells,
or pluripotent stem cells
that we can reprogram from people.
I can do it from my cells,
from your cells as well.
So from these single cells, we
grow them in different media,
changing the growth factors,
specific growth factors
at different stages,
until we can mature
them and these networks
will just form and become
more and more sophisticated.
Another thing is that,
I mean they can grow
up to a half centimeter
and we can keep them alive
for up to two years, so these
are quite robust protocols,
because not only you create a single one,
but it can create thousands
of brain organoids
in the same batch, so that allows you
to do some experiments with them.
If you cut one of those spheres,
what you can see is that they maintain,
or they mimic, some of the
embryonic brain structures
in humans, by having a
ventricular zone in the center,
that's stem cells that migrate out
and form what we call the cortical plate.
As these organoids age,
these cortical layers
will become more and more well-defined.
So this is a snapshot
of all the cell types
that we have if we just aged
these brain organoids
for about four month.
We have mostly glutamergic,
these excitatory neurons
and you start to see two
populations in there,
so these would be upper
and lower cortical layers,
but we also have
inhibitory neurons as well.
It's more a population
of GABAergic neurons.
There are progenitor cells
that continue to produce,
and at that stage, we start to see
some glia cells, or astrocytes.
These are the cell types
that helps on the formation
of these complex networks
that I'm gonna show you
how they behave later on.
So this is all good, but I
need live cells to recreate
those brain organoids in a
dish, and the problem is,
there is no live cells
from the Neanderthals.
So that poses a big problem:
how can we recreate a Neanderthal mind
if we don't have the
raw material for that?
So, we turn to genetics
since we have their genome.
One thing that is possible to do,
is compare the genome of the Neanderthals
to modern humans, and we
have thousands of them,
and ask, what are the differences
between those genomes?
What is it specific to modern humans
that were positive selected
in us, compared to them?
So, if we look across all the genes,
we end up with about 200 genes,
and this is, many people have
been mining this data set
and these are the genes that are different
between modern humans and Neanderthals.
Instead of looking for all these genes,
we decided to narrow down
this list to three genes,
because we asked, what are the ones
that are highly expressed
during the early stages
of neural development
and what are the ones
that we know if they are
mutated in modern humans,
will lead to a neurological disorder?
And these are the three
genes, these two here
are synaptic genes, to
help how the synaptic
or the connections between
neurons are formed,
and that one is a very interesting one
'cause they start very early
and it's a master regulator
of several downstream genes,
it's a splicing regulator,
splicing protein.
So, the way we do that
is using genome editing
and we use CRISPRs where we can go back
to one of our modern human cell lines
and we can change or swap
the genetic information
from the modern humans to the Neanderthal,
so we Neanderthalize the cell lines,
targeting those specific genes,
and at the end of the day
we have Neanderthal brain organoids
or Neanderthoids how we call
them, and we can compare.
So, I mean we done that, we recreate that,
and I'll show you some of the differences
that we observe by comparing
them with the modern humans.
So the first big difference is
at the gene expression level.
What are the genes that
are up or downregulated,
compared to us, and we
have a couple of them.
The interesting part is
that they are all connected
to brain development and several pathways
that leads to brain formation.
Now I'll point to some of them here,
this is just a list of interesting genes
that we are trying to understand.
There are genes such as nestin
which is a progenitor cell,
early stages of neuro brain formations.
There are genes such as TBR1.
This is a gene that has
been implicated in autism,
for example, and they are
downregulated in Neanderthals.
There are genes like OTX,
that when upregulated,
might prone you to have
seizures or epilepsy,
so this all happens without
genetic modification,
I mean, it's just by
changing those early genes
that you affect downstream
genetic signature
that might lead to problems
such as autism or epilepsy.
So, I told you about one of the genes
that are actually a master regulator
and controls how gene expression
or splicing is regulated,
and this is a gene called NOVA1,
and this is a reconstruction
of the protein
attached to the RNA, and
exactly the base pair
from the DNA that changes
out of that conformation
and as a consequence, the RNA splicing
would be affected as well.
And we are looking into
these outer splicing factors
and we realized that there is
a lot of information in there.
Some genes, like HOMER1, this
is another synaptic gene,
have a different isoforms between humans
and Neanderthals during development.
Other genes, and these
are actual target of NOVA1
such as GNAS or BIN1, so
these are genes involving
epigenetic regulation for example.
They create a new isoform
that's only present in Neanderthals.
Modern humans lost that isoform
from that specific protein.
So these are quite
interesting observations
at the gene expression level.
What happens to these brain
organoids if they have that?
So the morphology's quite interesting.
They start quite similar but
as they progress in time,
you can tell that the
morphology changes a lot,
so why are the modern
human's brain organoids
become sphere, increase in
size and start to mature,
Neanderthal brain organoids
have this kind of popcorn shape
and you can measure the diameter of them,
how they grow, and already we can see
that the Neanderthal organoids
probably have some kind of cell death
or some problems to develop,
compared to modern humans.
Also, the size of these
spheres is different
but also I mean the way those spheres
are shaped, which might point
it out to some differences
as I said, in cell death or apoptosis,
but also in migration,
the way the cells migrate.
So just by looking at these pictures,
we can tell that there
is migration defects
and there is a way to test that.
You can plate some of these cells,
and let them migrate by themselves,
and what we observe is
that the Neanderthal cells,
they have a defecting migration.
They migrate slower but they
go farther than human cells.
So even a small migration might affect
your entire brain's
trajectory during development.
So if you look at the neurons,
I mean we also see a
difference in specific subtype
of populations from the cortex of,
this is one of the cortical layers,
and we observed that SATB2,
a neuron that participates
on intracortical communication
as well as intracommunications
between layers,
it is dramatically reduced
in the Neanderthal cell
lines compared to controls.
So, everything is all about morphology
and how the cells behave or
the shape of these organoids.
What about the function,
can we actually measure
how the communication of the
network has been affected?
So to do that, we use a tool
that is called a multielectrode array,
where we plate these brain
organoids into multielectrodes
into the bottom of those
dishes and we can record,
we gain an activity map
as well as a raster plot
and every trace here,
it's when a neuron spikes,
and if you have several
spikes at the same time,
we call that a burst,
and when bursts spikes
in the same channel we
call it a synchrony event.
And since we can keep them alive,
we can see that they
evolve, and we did that,
and when we start, we actually
didn't have one to compare,
so I'm showing here just some of the work
that we did in 2D, this is,
we dialed a three dimension restructure,
and most of the data,
it is below five hertz,
so this is just a average
measure of the brain activity,
so what is the idea, what is our goal?
So a mouse brain is about
18 hertz, and a monkey brain
is about 20 hertz, so other people
have also created different
protocols for brain organoids
and although they can also keep
them alive for a long period
of time, they were not able to
see an increase in activity,
suggesting that there is some
problems with maturation.
But, we are glad that
the protocol we have,
we were able not only to keep them alive
but to reach a level of
activity that's much higher
than was ever recorded before in vitro,
so if you have that much level of activity
in synaptogenesis going on,
it means that you can record
something else, and this is what we call
brain oscillations or brainwaves,
the activity that can actually measure
through the skulls using
electroencephalogram or EEG.
So we can actually measure those EEG waves
from these brain organoids,
and we can compare them
to preterm babies, so we
created these machine learning
algorithm and we train that
in an unsupervised way,
by exposing them to different
EEGs from preterm babies,
and asking the machine to
tell the age of the person.
So once the machine has
done that, we feed them
with our brain organoids' EEG and we ask,
what are the predicted
age of the organoids?
So, this is how the machine will do
in a perfect condition, in the red trace.
The data is actually on
the black trace as well.
You can see that we have
a very good prediction,
above 25 weeks, and the reason why
the machine is not good
to predict below that,
is because we simply don't have any data
from human preterm babies below that.
The babies will die, and we
don't have a way to record
in utero, that is non-invasive.
So that's why we don't
have a good prediction.
But what is the prediction
that we can have?
And I'll show you just one
example of one of the parameters
from the EEG which is the
space between the interval
of activities, so if we just look
at an adult EEG here,
so it's quite complex.
This is a preterm baby, you see
these spontaneous activity transient
followed by a quiescent period
where the brain is just silent,
when you're super young,
and here is our brain
organoid, so the brain organoid
is much similar to a preterm
baby than to adult brain,
so that's what we're modeling.
We're modeling early
stages of neurodevelopment.
So, as we grow older, the
interval between those activities
become shorter and
shorter, that's why we have
this complex EEG in adult.
So the organoid, as we age the organoid,
the interval also reduces,
and reduces to a level
that gets close to that
red bar, about 40 weeks
or nine month, that's
equivalent to a newborn
healthy human baby, so
that's what we can get
with these human organoids.
So now that we have lots
of activity to compare,
I mean, how does the
Neanderthal brain organoids
compare to modern humans?
So we have been studying
that from different angles,
and I'll first start by
showing what is the level
of synaptogenesis, how
many brain cell connections
the Neanderthals can make
compared to modern humans?
And we see that it's almost 50% reduction
which is similar to someone
with autism, for example.
So definitely a lower level
of synapsis compared to controls.
We also measured them on
the multielectrode arrays,
and what we have here in this part
is just the raster plot, the activity map,
and then some of the
contrafigurations that we have.
The number of spikes,
the level of activity
per neuron per minute, is way reduced
to what we expect for an isogenic control.
The same is true for the
firing rate for these neurons
is also reduced compared
to isogenic controls,
which again points to the
fact that these networks
are just not good enough,
or not mature enough,
to the level that we would
expect from modern humans.
So, I hope I could tell you that,
by recreating these
Neanderthal brain in a dish
we could say that they have
differences in morphology,
synaptogenesis, even at the network level,
but the question is, are those differences
better or worse than the modern human's?
And I made like some analogies with autism
and other neurological
disorders, but the truth is
that we don't know, so we
have been looking at that
using different experimental models,
and I'll just show you one
thing that we are excited about,
and this came from this
idea that if you have
brain oscillations from
people working together,
they might actually synchronize
or they are more prone
to work if your friend is
with you, than a stranger,
which suggests that to achieve something,
to achieve a specific goal,
it's better to work with someone
that you like, so we have been tagging
these human brain organoids into robots,
so that's a way for the robot
to experiment in the world,
and we are doing that in two ways.
The first step is just teaching
the organoid how to move a robot,
and that's what you're going
to be seeing in this video.
So this is a robot that is
being moving all the legs,
just by the frequency of oscillations
coming from the human brain organoid,
so the idea is now to do the second step,
which is to create the feedback loop,
so the organoid can
actually learn something
and the robot can tell by
experiencing the world.
So soon we're going to be
doing the same experiments
using Neanderthal brain organoids.
We can see if the robot can actually
learn something better
or not, than humans.
So, I'll finish here by
summarizing that we have a model,
brain organoid model
coming from stem cells
that can recapitulate human development.
We can reconstruct evolutionary
steps that recapitulate
key features of the Neanderthal
development, we think so,
and this might be a paradigm for learning
if you put them back to
a robot or something.
So these are Cleber and Priscilla,
these are the brain masters in the lab,
they are the ones who
developed these nice protocols
that everybody's excited about,
and these are my collaborators
for this project.
Both Katerina Semendeferi,
Yeo Lab, the VOYTEKlab,
and Eric Green who helped us
on the general genomic
analysis of Neanderthals.
And these are my funding agencies,
and I'll stop here, thank you very much.
(audience applauds)